hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield episode 20 video
lots of awesome stuff to talk about so
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet starting with top
five moments here we go
number five Ward and agent 33 take Bobby
hostage they didn't wait long they
explained what agent 33 was doing inside
shield if there's anything about him
that you've been able to count on the
back half of the season is that he's
always going to lie they said they were
gonna kill Bobby but the problem is is
that Mockingbird is supposed to be like
one of the leads on the spin-off series
so we know she's gonna be fine but what
kind of chaos are they gonna try and
cause with that quintet it was a big
twist but but a lot of the WTF a lot of
the reason why I was shaking my head is
because how did Bobby get separated from
the other quinjets
and they not notice it and how did they
all leave the base with two maze may was
on the other quinjets so they would have
had to have left like before Bobby left
otherwise she would have seen two maze
walking around as creepy as their
relationship seems I totally think that
wart is playing agent 33 he has some
goal in mind he's probably just
exploiting her it just feels like their
chemistry is too forced like if he was
acting like a quarterback in season 1
now he's acting like mr. Casanova bad
guy it's still an act so we just need to
wait for the moment for war to throw her
under the bus to the bus that exploded
last week that we all miss very dearly
moving on to number 4 no one wants to
trust Rayna even if her visions are
right shocking twist number 2 Rayna was
actually trying to help she wasn't
trying to deceive them the bait and
switch with Gordon was a little hard to
follow so here's what's going on
Rayna tried to get Gordon to take giant
be around and Rayna could go meet with
shield
Gordon clearly came clean to jiying so
jayegi had Rayna held while they
conducted her meeting and it looks like
jiying had always planned to use that
synthetic Terrigen crystal it wasn't
like she decided on a dime from the
minute she knew shield was coming to
afterlife that was probably her plan
Raina's past has come to bite her in the
ass Cal said that you know she's not
evil she's not outright evil it's just
that before she became an inhuman she
had issues with averies if she were a DC
character she'd be an orange Lantern and
now that her vision of the the craziness
with shield is coming true what I'm
wondering is is if
visions are always destined to become
true there's no way to avert them it's
like a self-fulfilling prophecy you
learn the future you try to avoid it by
doing something different but in doing
so you bring about the outcome you were
originally trying to avoid as if the
future is always permanent Marvel has
not done the time gem yet so they
haven't really addressed the issue of
changing the timeline there's a
difference between seeing the future and
being a prophet on to number 3 Mac bails
on shield this is a really sad scene but
he did have that nice moment with
Coulson but you know even though he
hated what Coulson was doing Coulson was
still like you know we're really sad to
lose you he recognized how important Mac
is to their team this is the foundation
for a lot of what's gonna be going on in
Captain America Civil War you have a lot
of heroes that respect each other but
just like fundamentally disagree with
what's going on
so this brothers just say you know what
peace I can't do this anymore I'm
quitting the Avengers the really
interesting thing though is that Mac
said he's gonna go back to the destroyer
which is which is not the Helicarrier if
you're confused even though they look
kind of similar he's gonna go back to
get his stuff but that is exactly where
the Kree monolith is he made this big
speech about messing with stuff that you
don't understand does he know about the
monolith I wonder as far as we know that
monolith is the most dangerous thing on
the show right now as far as they've
explained it they dug it up a hundred
years ago so it's not something that
they've addressed on the show before
they didn't find it where the Nazis
found the diviners in Episode one so
it's like a completely separate thing
there's not a lot of references to
something like that in the comic books
so just think of it as another version
of that Hydra weapon that incinerates
people only it's designed to only work
on Inhumans it's like a reverse diviner
as cool as it was you know shifting from
liquid to solid I think it shifts to
liquid when it's in the presence of
Inhumans that's just as active form we
don't know if it has any kind of
intelligence as far as we know right now
it's just a tool like the diviner but I
think it's kind of funny that Mac spent
all that time shaking his fist in
Coulson's face about messing with stuff
you don't understand and he's going
right in the direction of something
really dangerous that he doesn't
understand
it's like saying you're afraid of fire
and running into a burning building onto
number two the Patton Oswalt intro
explains theta protocol sometimes the
way shield starts its episodes
so perfect this is patton oswalt one is
just so funny so nonchalant like he's
just humming along just having fun in
his bunker by himself turns out there's
a giant Helicarrier they'll building in
it so the episode serves is another
intact
age of Ultron the Helicarrier that we
saw in the big battle was theta protocol
some of the really minor things to love
about this are Patton Oswalt's Star Wars
sheets the call of duty and the lanyards
his character is like the quintessential
Marvel collector I'm sure he has a shelf
with action figures somewhere what else
do you gonna do when you have an
assignment like that though I mean
you're stuck in an underground bunker
you're gonna have to have some fun
somehow and finally my number one WTF
moment jiying activates a synthetic
Terrigen crystal seemingly you know
starting off a big conflict with shield
the war hasn't started yet there haven't
been any giant explosions but but that's
the promise for like this big two-hour
finale it's gonna be a big Inhumans
versus shield battle because of what she
did it does seem like jiying is the
antagonist but that's not the case they
want to cast a lot of doubt as to who
they want you to root for because like
the non Coulson shield people are kind
of and the Inhumans could
totally take a left turn and go rogue so
barring some crazy WTF from Ward there
is no clear villain in this situation
although I don't think there's any way
they're gonna end the season without
there being a villain someone will rise
up and do something really terrible
inside you know these two big groups of
people just to explain the synthetic
crystals she said that they made them
because they didn't have enough diviners
to last but in reverse engineering the
diviners the Terrigen crystals ended up
mixing with materia from the diviners so
you wind up with something that ends up
being just like those Hydra weapons if
you were a normal person and you
breathed in Terrigen mist nothing would
happen
it just it wouldn't affect you it
wouldn't activate any powers the Ovilus
technology is what turns you into stone
that's what Hydra reverse-engineered but
there was this big running thing in this
episode of people good people
replicating Hydra technology shield
found the Inhumans replicating Hydra
tech you know the exploit that they
found with Deathlok Simmons used Hydra
tech to try and kill Ward and Jiang's
weapon is also kind of like Hydra tech
and that it incinerates people so it's
almost like everyone's a bad guy right
now how do you guys feel about that
sometimes it's hard to know who to root
for when everyone is at
really bad but I think that that just
dovetails really nicely with the themes
in Captain America Civil War so here's
my big question for you guys you know
unless someone else steps forward who do
you think is the villain right now out
of the caste that we have on screen
right now assuming that you know no Deus
Ex mashin it happens in some other big
villain rises from somewhere that we
haven't seen we can blame jogging going
crazy on all that blue meth she's been
cooking make as many agents of shield
breaking bad jokes as you want I always
feel like the best episodes of TV are
really funny and really WTF just like
shocking twists but also moments that
make you just laugh your ass off so
here's what the schedule is gonna be
next week's episode is actually gonna be
two episodes jammed together it'll be a
two-part finale so it'll be like a
two-hour long episode even though it's
technically two episodes so be sure to
subscribe to get my video I'll post it
after the episode airs there's all kinds
of you know Inhumans bonus video stuff
we can talk about in the off season
she'll definitely coming back and
everyone's still wondering about agent
Carter hopefully they'll have some
updates about that but we have the
spin-off series to talk about - there's
still a couple episodes left of air on
the flash - so new arrow tonight I'll
post that video after the episode airs
it's gonna be a really good couple of
weeks of TV for superheroes just in
general you know I feel like shield has
done a much better job this season than
it did in season one it's been much more
consistent so it's gonna be a lot of fun
to speculate on what's gonna be going on
in season 3
definitely more Inhumans I think we can
at least assume that so while you guys
wait for that stuff to post you can
click here to learn about the biggest
cuts that they made to age of Ultron and
you can click here for all my other
agents of shield videos thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you